[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 133 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am mock mantle and I'm here as always
with my colleague Melanie Warwick
Melanie how are you doing today good how
are you doing mark I'm very well very
very well unfortunately we're not in the
same place at the same time No
then this week in particular you're in
Denmark yeah when this comes out I'll be
in Denmark so mark who do we have on the
show this week so today we have Brahim
from the Android team and session from
the firebase team coming to talk to us
about ml kit I'm kind of excited about
this I think I love these packaged
machine learning solutions they've been
very excited and the previous week we
were even referencing that you know hand
talk was looking forward to ml kit so
this is good yeah good timing before we
get stuck into that though we have our
cool things of the week and then at the
end we'll have our question of the week
we're going to talk more about devrel
we're gonna talk about what is a
developer programs engineer yes we will
as you mentioned mark we as always like
to start out with the cool things of the
week we actually wanted to note that our
tenth doodle for google winner is
dynomite as the blog terrible horrible
Sarah Gomez Lane apparently drew a
delightful dinosaurs that highlight her
dream of becoming a paleontologist so
there's this really cute image that she
did that's got dinosaurs and I really
kind of love it and I know Asha who's
one of our teammates would love this as
well absolutely I know what I love about
this as well is if the first time in the
doodle for Google's 10-year history the
winner has the opportunity to actually
turn their submission into an animated
interactive doodle that'll both featured
on the Google homepage so I for one am
very much looking forward to seeing
dinosaurs that a hand drawn on it
apparently she's got a nice chunk of
reward for the the drawing as well to go
towards our college scholarship which is
wonderful so that's awesome yeah I think
that's great one thing I wanted to
highlight as well as everyone in our
audience is aficionados of podcasts
there is a new Google podcast app that
you can grab on Android that's available
for you that you can garrote and
download we'll have a link in the show
notes it has some nice integrations with
things like Google home and all the
Google fun stuff there I just figured
I'd mention it because of course you can
now grab the Google cloud platform
podcast on there as well
and it has some nice features about you
know being able to play in one place and
pick up where you left off in others and
stuff like that so just thought you know
podcast people would like podcast things
another thing we wanted to mention is
that there was another course that's
been released between Google and
Coursera around machine learning we know
there was a crash course that we
mentioned a little while back and
there's apparently a new course out
that's more for specializing in machine
learning with an emphasis on tensorflow
and so they have five specific focuses
in the courses around like how Google
does machine learning in this
specialization launching into machine
learning what tensorflow is feature
engineering and the art and science of
machine learning and so yeah you can
find that on Coursera fancy lots of new
and interesting things today so also
introducing cloud dataflow has a new
streaming engine which is super nice it
basically has a bunch of different and
interesting and useful performance
enhancements for how to do streaming on
data flow what's super nice about it is
basically if you want to try it there's
a new pipeline parameter you can do - -
experiment sequel's enabled streaming
engine you'd have to change your code or
anything like that you can just
basically turn it on eventually once
this goes generally availability it'll
literally just switch on by default and
you'll just get new good stuff just
because but if you want to give it a go
make sure nothing breaks you know see if
the fixes work for you give it a go noun
and give it a shot and the blog that we
link to includes a nice overview about
how to think about pricing as well as
where to get started yep absolutely
last thing we wanted to mention is
there's a blog post by Barret Williams
who has written about how to use the
cloud - speech app as well as the
text-to-speech app and he does a nice
overview explanation of how to implement
these tools and what to do with them
yeah it's like a really nice sort of
hello world of taking speech tuning into
text then taking text and turning it to
speech even touches on SS ml in here -
which we talked about in a previous
episode well mark I think it's time that
we go talk about ml kit let's go do it
so recently at Google i/o I got excited
to see a new product announcement about
ml kit from firebase and today I'm
pretty excited to have both session
Kalani product manager from firebase and
brahim el Bellini no SLE bikini abou
Shiki there
brahim el Bhushan group product manager
for Android joining us today
yeah I kind of get names right for
joining us
session how you doing today doing great
so glad to be here yeah for him how are
you doing I'm doing great
thank you so much for joining us before
we get stuck into MLK which I really
want to do do you want to tell us a
little bit about who you are and what
you do session whether you go first sure
so I've been at Google for a little over
over eight years I've been a product
manager for most of those and I've been
on the Google Play team where I first
got the chance to work with their Brahim
I also worked on the platform team on
developer tools and over the past year
I've been on the firebase team and I
work on ml kitna excellent Ibrahim
Hey yes so I've been at Google for
almost seven years
starting off also on on Google Play and
Android then moved on to do some VR
stuff at daydream and then for past year
I've been leading I work on machine
learning on Android
now I spent a bunch of my time with ml
kit as well as other things that you
know networks API for hardware
acceleration tensorflow light and such
so yeah lots of fun ml stuff that's
great well so what is ml kit okay so a
milk it is essentially Google's machine
learning SDK available through firebase
any greater deeply into firebase it
offers a couple of capabilities one is
what we call base api's these are api's
that essentially allow you to do stuff
you get an input and you get an output
there is essentially as far as the
developer is concerned no machine
learning involved Google provides the
machine learning models and it makes
them available through a simple API so
that's one set of things and then the
other aspect is essentially enabling
developers to use their own custom
models and making that as easy as
possible that is something that Sachin
is deeply familiar with so I'm gonna
maybe ask you to jump in and talk a bit
about that searching sure before I jump
into that actually also want to talk
about one cool thing about base API set
I think it's it's very interesting and
different from from what we've seen thus
far in the space is that ml kit offers a
PS I run both on device or in cloud
and depending on the functionality you
want to use SMA PS are available to run
fully on device some are only available
in the cloud and some offer the option
of using one or the other and of course
if you want to do something more
powerful the capabilities will be there
in the cloud API but if you want to do
something locally you would do that on
device now for the custom models if you
are an expert in machine learning you
know ml kit first and foremost positions
itself as a tool that makes it very easy
to bring machine learning to your apps
but if you're already familiar with
tensorflow creating your own models you
can also use ml kit to deliver those
models to to your developers and you
would upload your custom model and it
would be seamlessly deployed to the
users device without them having to
download anything manually so that
infrastructure piece is taken care of we
are just getting started there there's a
lot more to come in the near future but
that's an area that we are really
passionate about as well just so or how
everything clear as well I think you
both said apps are we talking about this
is machine learning for mobile devices
is that is that kind of the market we're
talking about right here that's correct
okay cool so you said as well there's a
bunch of built in ml kit functionality
that people don't have to build
themselves what what is that
functionality that's available the ones
that are there right now out of the box
are text extraction face detection
barcode recognition image labeling and
landmark recognition those are the ones
that are available today and as you know
probably recognize they're mostly around
vision for now in terms of these api's
how would they integrate with something
that's like the API is in the GCP
environment the Google cloud platform
environment that's a great question so
as I mentioned earlier these api's or
these use cases are available both on
device and cloud the ones that are
available in cloud are run on top of the
Google cloud platform ml api's so
they're using you know underlying it all
is the same ap is for for the cloud
version of it this sounds really cool
brahim maybe you can talk to this
because you seem to be on the Android
side of things what were the needs that
you were seeing from customers who
wanted to be able to do like machine
learning on mobile devices once we
started looking at this some time ago we
realized that one is the apps are
actually using
learning on device right this isn't
something that's entirely new we
actually came across a bunch of
developers who have been able to do this
however there were a lot of challenges
it was quite difficult and that was for
a number of reasons one is building a
model itself and the fact that you
needed a lot of training data and then
you needed a lot of not only training
data but also the ability to create a
mobile optimized model that was quite
challenging for developers we met some
developers that had built their own
runtimes on device just to execute
tensorflow models because at the time
there weren't any available runtimes
like tensorflow Lite which we have right
now so there are a lot of challenges
when we looked out there that made
machine learning on apps quite
challenging and we wanted to address a
lot of those initially so for example we
came across apps that from a use case
perspective that did like music learn
and you know so basically you have an
instrument you're playing on an analog
guitar like in a real actual instrument
and the phone is recording what you're
playing and trying to assess how well
you're playing well actually a lot of
that is happening to on device machine
ear models that are tuned to echo
cancellation to environment your way
into the specific learning patterns you
have and then we talk to specific
developers that do that like like
musician for example is an app that's on
Android and iOS we came across you know
apps that help you manage what you're
eating and kind of your calorie intake
we came across a fitness apps that try
to track your movement or apps that
allow you to to scan in content so for
example Evernote is using machine
learning to allow you to take a picture
of a whiteboard and any kind of indexes
what's in it allow you to search for it
later on
so one thing we quickly learned is that
this stuff is is useful it's actually
used by few developers but it's very
challenging it's way too challenging for
it to become common use and so our goal
was to and then can I we repeated this
across kind of launch of ml kit was to
kind of make ml not so special right now
like machinery is like special thing you
needed lots of Education you need a lot
of background you need a lot of
experience in math and other things like
that to use it but we wanted to just be
actually just another toolkit that the
developer has access to it they can
solve specific problems with when they
need them
and so that was kind of the goal and the
mission behind the market from day one
so to summarize yeah we looked out there
were use cases for it it was used in
practice but it was way too challenging
and so we wanted to address some of
those tanks and with ml kit features
that we have that we've launched and
some that we are still launching in the
next few months it sounds awesome I'm
guessing I can probably picture what
this looks like but in session maybe you
can talk to this so if I actually want
to use ml kit as a developer I assume
these are like baked into the firebase
SDKs is that how I would use them what
does this look like that's correct so
depending on what capabilities you want
to use there modularized in different
firebase SDKs but you know just with a
couple of lines and you build up grader
or your pod file you can get this
capability added I must confess here you
know when the team was building ml kit I
was really looking forward to the
experience as a developer as a hacker
myself just to jump in and start using
the api's and as I said you know just
you just add a few lines to build a
Gradle file depending on what ap as you
want to use and then once you have an
image or a set of images you can start
calling those api's on them and you can
have a prototype working you know if it
took me about 15 minutes to get working
I would expect the average listener of
this podcast to do to do it much faster
that's brahim was saying we wanted to
make ml not so special and very easy to
use and that's what we aim to do with ml
k very simple to use ap is nice that
sounds great and I know you also
mentioned that this could be run both on
the phone as well as in the cloud is
there a difference in capabilities
between the two offerings there or
they're the same brahim I see you
nodding your head you want to answer
that question yeah yeah sure I mean I
think the the benefits of on-device
there's always trade-offs obviously like
everything else in life on device what
you get is the real time aspects you
don't need to upload a ton of data to
the cloud obviously so it is they can be
a privacy sensitive approach to machine
learning and also it's actually free of
charge
it runs on device and so the API itself
the use of the API itself is free to the
developer so those are some big points
but of course you also get limitations
on the cloud you have the power of DCP
you have the power of TP use you have
essentially the ability to run and
execute incredibly large models that
give you more so for example if you look
at our image labeling API which we have
both the cloud and an on device
variation of it
the cloud variation has over 10,000
labels meaning they can tell you about
10,000 things about this image that
you've submitted the on device one has
little over 400 so you can do what we've
seen developers do typically is due
course classification on device where
they essentially look for interesting
things so let's say I'm I'm trying to
classify an image and make sure that I
only do the cloud call if I see that
there is some food in the image so maybe
I will actually or maybe plants or
flowers and so maybe I'll run the on
device API see if I get any keywords
that I'm looking for like a flower or
plant or something like that
and if I do then I'm like oh okay I
actually want to know specifically what
kind of flower this is then I'm gonna
call the Google cloud platform API to
then get the the more fine-grain
classification and so we do things these
pairings we see developers do this in a
number of places and we actually are
also investing in making sure these
transitions are even more seamless and
even in building kind of use cases and
journeys are end-to-end built to be what
we call hybrid we have a bunch of
exciting stuff coming up there in the
future
but but we see this as a as an
increasingly common use case of kind of
relying on both cloud and on device I
mean I know you mentioned that a lot of
the api's are geared towards more visual
what are some functionalities that are
api's that you would like to see or
you're you're seeing more of a need for
from the different people that you work
with you know it's still early days so
we're still trying to gather that
feedback and see what the what the
requests are but you can you know
obviously imagine that some of the
things that we're starting to talk about
our speech video you know it follows
closely after after image but again it's
it's early days we would love to hear
from from developers from the listeners
of the podcast if they have any
suggestions on what they would like to
see next for now I'd also like to add
and as brahim said this is an area that
I'm passionate about that we do have the
capabilities for for custom models so if
there are any specific capabilities that
can be run intensive low-light models
developers would like to use those they
can deploy them immediately they can
have pulled their tensile for like
models 2 ml kit and start using them for
on device inference and of course
there's always the GCP capabilities
therefore someone wants to run a tensor
flow model in the cloud you can interact
with those as well are there any
resources you'd recommend especially
around you know models that maybe
somebody has done custom models that
others have done that are sharing them
and open sourcing them yeah that's a
great question tensorflow has website
called tensor flow hub and that's one of
the things that they do is share
snippets of code or or pre bundled
modules that people can leverage to
create their own models and you know as
for completed models goes of course the
usual suspects apply you can always look
on github or hacker news or any of you
know medium post that there's a pretty
active community out there building
tensor flow models now I'd like to call
out that what AM L Kids supports is
tensorflow light models so you probably
also want to visit the tensorflow Lite
website to see what mods are already
available in the tents of a lite format
and how to go about converting
tensorflow models to transfer for light
just out of curiosity as well I was
reading that just takes two years we
were sitting here what's the difference
there between tensorflow and tensorflow
light just so people have at least a
broad understanding of what that
difference is tensorflow light is
obviously like born out of tensorflow
it's it's essentially an extension of
kinds of flow it is built with mobile in
mind and so effectively the runtime is
much smaller
it goes from over a Meg to about 200
kilobytes the storage uses flatbuffers
so that the the storage of the models is
far more efficient and smaller and he
also has a more limited set of apps that
have been optimized for mobile devices
over time the team is looking to expand
number of operators and also the number
of capabilities that it has beyond just
this operators but we're very much
taking kind of star with what's most
needed on mobile and then extend expand
from there
TF light comes tensorflow light comes
with a set of tools that allow you to
convert a model from tensorflow to be
tensorflow
light compatible that can also be done
in the cloud through some of ml kits
services but it does come with with an
offline tool that can do that as well
the team is continuing to release a
bunch of cool stuff I'm really excited
about their roadmap to around tools that
allow you to compress models and you
know they things like quantization of
models that allow you to have vastly
more efficient mobile centric models so
lots lots and lots happen in there but
yeah it is it is essentially an
extension intensive low and Annie was
built from the ground up with with
performance and mobile in mind you know
I'm very mobile centric but but the
tensorflow like team actually is is it
they care a lot about things like you
know sevilla bond raspberry pie it's
available for you know they're working
on IOT they're working on kind of tiny
tiny little sensors that can run the
models tensorflow light is kind of
tensorflow beyond kind of server side
and so they did cover a ton of different
platforms and they're pretty versatile
cool and just are my hosting clear as
well tensorflow light models can only be
run on device so can it be both on
device and in the cloud that's a great
question I don't know if anyone's ever
you know we've never tried turning it
into a light model in the cloud I have
no idea about machine learning so I just
ask silly questions it's a computer
wouldn't do it because you know the
point of it is that is far more limited
yeah I guess my point is it's you would
build this specifically for running on
device and that's its purpose so you
would do that ok got it
absolutely it's yes it's optimized for
mobile and that's what he would use it
for well great
what other things have we not covered
around you know mo kit and how how
useful it is for those who are working
on Android or working in IOT or looking
at devices what are some other tips and
tricks that you'd recommend I have a
couple of things I think is quite
important one is that MLK does cross
platform so it's actually iOS and
Android and this was really important
for us you know someone who's on the
Android team you know one of the first
things I asked my execs for is like hey
we're gonna need IRS engineers and
that's because when we talk to
developers they think of machine
learning as a thing they don't think of
Android machine learning and iOS machine
learning and so it's very important that
we offer a cross-platform solution and
we think that is actually one of the
most compelling in addition to ours in
the capability server that's a very
unique differentiator of MLK that were
excited about that's number one the
other aspect I wanted to highlight is
the fact that no it's
by making MLK not-so-special one of the
key things about that was that hey there
are a bunch of like traditional mobile
challenges that developers care about
you know things like binary size and a
be testing and all this other stuff that
had been essentially you know not
impossible but really hard for ml so
today if let's say you wanted to a/b
test two models you really had to bundle
to potentially ten Meg models each and
then you'll be stuck with them you
bundle em into the apk or Chevy apk
they'll do some offline testing and
you're stuck with those two models for
the duration of your experiment you
cannot really iterate any faster than
your apk release and you know developers
have been trying to solve these problems
for a long time and they've been solved
from mobile there's many many platforms
most notably firebase which has things
like remote config and a be testing and
GE Google Analytics and so we wanted to
bring and solve some of these like just
mobile challenges for machine learning
and so a lot of the custom model stuff
that we've built as a round model
deployments are a band of an apk updates
or using remote config to actually name
the model and then retrieve the right
model based on what experiment group
you're in so we made essentially
experimenting with ml models literally a
one-line change in in in your app and
that's something that you know Sachin is
is really really invested in and pushing
in the envelope further and further in
that direction but just wanted to
reiterate that is when we said we want
ml to be not so special we weren't just
solving machine learning problems we
weren't just thinking about how to build
the best and greatest models we were
also thinking about hey like how do we
solve stuff that developers just care
about like apk size and so I don't know
such an you wanna dig into the
compression stuff from an apk size
perspective yeah so you know one of the
one of the things that I want to
reiterate the brahim was saying first
was ml kit doesn't exist in isolation
with in firebase right there's a reason
why it's there it's because firebase
offers an additional you know very very
broad set of tools that are useful and
services that are useful for mobile
developers remote config analytics you
know and a/b testing are just a few
examples within the ML kit family itself
model compression
and conversion it's a specific use case
for tensorflow
models so let's say you want to do image
classification and you have a model that
you have invested a lot of time and
effort and perhaps you have a research
team that optimizes them to make them
work really well and to increase the
precision and now you want to get it
working on mobile we have a
functionality that would convert the
tensor for light not only converted from
tensor flow test flow life right but
also compress it to make sure that it
runs efficiently and and doesn't take
too much storage space on the device so
that's you know that's one area that mom
that we're still actively working on we
are testing it with a few partners right
now we talked about fish brain in in
other forums as well they took models
that that were several hundred Meg's and
sizes and as reduced them by a factor of
ten without losing much precision at all
and actually I think in their particular
case we were able to even increase it
which is great so that's about
compression and conversion another area
that I'm really excited about and evokes
asked about typical use cases you know
that our developers and our early
partners would use MLK for what area
that I'm really excited about is about
what developers come up with because
machine learning is such a different
paradigm from any other software
development you know you can download a
library you can add some UI you can
change a data base right there's a
common concepts that are great it's
still important very much alive but
machine learning is so different from
any of that and it can provide such
different capabilities so that's one
area that I'm really excited about is to
see what new things developers build
when it comes to these tools actually
just one thing I want to make sure I'm
clear on when you're talking about ml
kit and running especially custom models
all of this is from the inference side
is imil kit also geared to help people
do training of models the short answer
is not at the moment there are lots of
investments around on device learning
that's one area the one area that we're
looking at there's things in our federal
earning where is Google published a
paper on that about a year or two ago
it's for those are curious so super
super cool paper to read but yeah not
saying nothing in the immediate current
we that allows us to help with training
but it's something you guys heaven in
your mind as what you're looking at yeah
it's absolutely our mind and and we know
that you know google cloud is making
investments in that area as well to auto
ml and others and so we're definitely
working across Google to make that a
reality on America I got asked the tough
question
this sounds great for mobile but
firebase supports the web are we gonna
get some JavaScript API is for some of
this stuff anytime soon of course the
tough question goes to me that's a great
question and I want to get that you know
add that question more and more because
the more we get that question the board
means that we should be working in that
aspect so you know for now as I said it
works on Android and iOS we are hearing
from a few developers that they would
like to see it in in mobile and I've one
as I said keep hearing that for now if
anyone wants to do machine learning on
the web I would point them to tensorflow
yes there are obviously a lot of models
at our open source and available and
ready to use in tensorflow format so
that's one way to go for now awesome and
anything that you want to talk about
it's potentially exciting on the roadmap
for ML kit that people should keep an
eye out for oh man there are so many
exciting things and I don't know if I
can talk about any of them brahim it's
like looking at me like do not say I
mean I mean I think some of the stuff
that one is obviously reiterating that
what we have in the market now you know
it's it's you know things like image
labeling API is is sometimes like
mind-boggling like you have an API that
on device you give it an image it tells
you what's in it that is that is super
cool definitely
we also are super excited about the new
face contour API in a beta right now we
were testing with a few developers so
that's gonna be super cool and and if
you see it you saw a demo such in doing
this at i/o it's now a legendary get
within the team so that's gonna be super
exciting and just look for us to kind of
keep pushing you know the promise we
made to developers quite publicly at i/o
is that we will be knocking on Google
researchers doors and asking them to
bring their capabilities to developers
and the nice to use easy to use package
and working
to do that behind the scenes or
continuing to push for making Google's
best machinery and technologies
available through a Mel kit and kind of
dusty that's a generic promise we're
making in terms of specifics I think
will will we'll have to leave it there
was coming now as a white list and all
that good stuff well thank you both
again for coming on the podcast to talk
to us about ML KITT just any additional
last minute like plugs or things you're
speaking out of resources you want to
let people know about yeah you know I
just really encourage everyone to to
give em okay to try you know I at least
from the experience and you know the fun
part of it and just getting up and
running really quick and and seeing
results it's a very very rewarding
experience so I'd love for all of you to
try it out and to let us know what you
think and what you would like to see
next you know we are we have quite a lot
of things that we have in mind that we
want to work on and deliver soon but we
also look forward to hearing from all of
you to learn what things you'd like to
see next
fantastic well thank you to both of you
for coming and hanging out with us today
all right well just to close you know
not to date this not to date this
podcast but it is a world cup and go
Morocco we're gonna beat Spain such as
team sometime next week so look out for
that thanks again brahim and session for
coming on the podcast to talk with us
about ml kit it was good to get that
overview and understand you know what
these tools are what the tool is and how
to use it yeah absolutely
so mark yes what is a developer programs
engineer well I'm not gonna try and
explain this because I'm a developer
advocate so you you don't know anything
about that as a developer I was gonna
say I haven't developer advocate
developer program engineers at least in
Google Cloud sit in the same
organization as we do so we have
developer relations you want to go
listen to the episode with Mandy I
definitely do and so DP es or develop a
program engineer sit next to us you know
we're peers I think is a nice way to put
it hang out and there's a really great
we hang out we totally hang out we all
sit together which is lovely and I'm
gonna hope I don't absolutely
secure their name there's a great
article from Francisca Hinkleman who is
the dpe at Google cloud platform
apparently doing a lot of no Jo stuff
and they write a really great article
about basically they explain how their
engineers in developer relations and
they sit at the intersection of
developer advocacy technical writing
product management and engineering and
so they they do a very similar role I
feel to what we do is to help advocates
with interacting with the community but
they definitely do it in a very
interesting way I feel like personally
from my perspective from the outside
they do it from almost a very code
perspective which i think is really cool
and they definitely do some really cool
things it's well worth the read yeah and
we did a podcast on data science a few
weeks back and Michelle Casper's was on
the podcast actually she's a DP so
agreed they have a nice intersection
into the Deverell space and agree it's a
good read mark where you gonna be where
are you this week where I'm on this week
so we mentioned previously that I am
gonna be in Denmark so last week on the
podcast if you were all listening and
I'm sure you were we mentioned very
briefly the unity announcement so we
announced that there's a strategic
alliance between unity and Google cloud
platform now which I'm particularly
excited about working in the game space
so definitely stay tuned to what's
happening there there's a lot of really
cool stuff going on there so basically
what I'm doing this week is I'm actually
going up to Denmark to participate in
Unity's internal hack week so they have
a week-long rnd week away I feel like
it's like summer camp I kind of feel
like I'm going to summer camp I'm gonna
go meet a whole bunch of new people that
I've never met before but once I leave
I'm gonna be friends with everybody that
sounds fun yeah it's a big rnd week so
I'm gonna go down there and hang out
with them and Hakan a bunch of stuff
it's gonna be really fun well good and
then come back and you'll have dialogue
I'll have to like it should be a lovely
exactly what do you up to great question
so this week and specifically tomorrow
I'm gonna be speaking to a group of
students who are participating in AI for
all and AI for all is a non-profit
working to increase diversity and
inclusion and artificial intelligence
yes this is based out of Stanford cool
so yeah that'll be tomorrow excellent
all right oh we should make a mention
that we'll both be a cloud next we
should probably talk about that
yeah next is coming up I haven't even
checked bed tickets are still on sale I
think let's find out yes you should come
and check it out July
24 through 26 tickets are on sale now we
can include that link in the show notes
but yeah will be it next we'll be
interviewing a bunch of people at next
so if you are going to be there come by
and say hi
definitely come by and say hi I will be
there so I'm speaking about Ohana's
which will be lots and lots of fun but
yeah we'll be doing daily episodes as
well while right next so expect lots of
good content and if you're there or
maybe soon class see if there's a little
slot for you to come hang out and do a
little quick interview we may also have
a few things to give out so you should
definitely come check us out mmm that
true thank you mark I think that's it
for us for this week yeah so thanks
again for joining me for another week on
the podcast Melanie thank you mark thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
[Music]
you